Welcome to the deep dive.
You know, sometimes it feels
like the headlines, especially
around immigration, just just
noise, right?
Absolutely.
So much heat, not always a lot
of light.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So today we're trying to cut
through that.
We're looking at something our
source material calls the big
beautiful Bunker Buster Bill.
Quite a title.
It is, but here's the twist.
We're not really focused on the
bill itself, not the clauses,
not the subsection.
It's more about what the bill
and, you know, all the intense
talk around it, what it tells us
about something deeper,
something often kind of unspoken
about America.
A hidden script almost.
That's the idea our source gives
us.
This really powerful kind of raw
perspective calls it a yap like
a shout.
Yeah, unfiltered.
Unfilter exactly.
And it comes with this, this
bone yard, basically a load of
history, economic facts,
different viewpoints.
So grounding the yap in some
reality.
Right.
Our goal here is to unpack the
really complex, often
contradictory, let's face it,
uncomfortable truths about
immigration in the US.
Moving beyond the usual Democrat
versus Republican sound bites.
Way beyond that, prepare to
maybe challenge some
assumptions.
You know, uncover what the
sources call the real script,
the one that doesn't fit neatly
anywhere.
OK, I'm ready.
Where do we start?
Let's start with the immediate
scene.
It's the 4th of July.
Congress just passed this big
beautiful bill, OK?
And our source describes the
whole thing, the bill, the
politics, using this term,
kayfabe.
Kayfabe from professional
wrestling.
Yeah, tell us about that.
What does that imply here?
Well, kayfabe is It's the
portrayal of staged events as
real.
Everyone involved, wrestlers,
promoters, even some fans.
They pretend the storylines, the
rivalries, are genuine.
So applying that to politics, it
suggests we're watching a
performance.
Exactly a kind of pre scripted
drama that everyone or many
people are treating as
completely real even when
there's maybe an underlying
agreement or different reality
happening.
And you see that reflected and
the reactions, right?
They're polar opposite.
On one side, you've got the
president supporters saying this
bill is like a last minute
redemption story, a new
declaration.
Strong language, almost
revolutionary sounding.
Totally a great unshackling for
the bureaucrats, the open
borders, even the parasites who
want to drink this country's
blood dry.
Really intense stuff.
Wow.
OK.
And the other side the.
Other side protesters holding
signs calling it Auschwitz 2
point O rounding up of the
other.
The dawn of the domestic
Gestapo.
So equally intense, just in the
opposite direction.
Fascism versus liberation.
Exactly.
But the analysis we're drawing
from says hold on.
The truth just refuses to land
neatly on one side or the other.
Right.
It pushes back against that
simple binary.
It argues America's story has
has never been just oppressor
versus oppress.
What is it then according to
this view?
It paints it more like like an
old circus, full of deals and
illusions and half true trade.
It's a circus.
I like that image.
Yeah, where everyone has a hand
on the lever and a foot on
someone else's back.
It suggests a much messier, more
complex interplay of power and
interest than the simple
narratives allow.
That idea of cafe, of
performance, it really changes
how you might look at things.
It does.
It prompts the question, if the
public square is a stage,
where's the backstage?
Where does the real script
actually play out?
So where does our source find
it?
It finds it somewhere
unexpected, or maybe very
expected if you're looking
closely.
A gas station parking lot in
Virginia.
A gas station.
Yeah, one that transforms by day
gas.
By night.
It becomes this bustling Cupusa
bar, concrete yard, plastic
tables.
You get the picture.
And the author apparently spent
like a decade there just
watching, listening, learning
what they call the real script.
And who are the actors in this
real script?
The main characters highlighted
are these guys called the
Drywall Kings.
And men working, you know, 12
hour days under a drywall cloud,
it's all cash under the table.
And maybe 80% of that cash gets
wired straight back home. 80%
Wow.
So what are they working for?
It's not the American Dream in
the classic sense, is it?
Not really.
It's much more specific, much
more tangible.
It's about, say, building a
concrete floor for the house
back home, or laying cinder
blocks for a second story,
buying a boat for cousins who
fish, or just making sure their
family has a warm winter in a
village somewhere far away.
So motivation is crystal clear.
Absolutely, Source puts it
bluntly.
They didn't come for the flag or
the anthem.
They came for the hustle.
The hustle.
Yeah.
They're described as invisible
men who turn paperless sweat
into real cinder blocks back
home.
It's about that direct economic
transaction, sweat equity.
Literally.
But this parking lot, this
pupusa bar, it's more than just
a labor market, isn't it?
The source talks about
community.
Oh, definitely.
It's portrayed as a place with
this, this really strong sense
of camaraderie, real connection.
How so?
Well, the author mentions things
like guys offering each other a
place to sleep if someone's just
arrived, sharing coffee, even
just laughing together about,
you know, not having a
girlfriend.
A Novia.
Kind of mutual support system.
Exactly, and the author
explicitly contrast this raw,
genuine connection with what
they call their own polite white
world, suggesting maybe
something vital is found there
that's missing elsewhere.
Interesting contrast.
So it's a complicated picture.
Very.
And the source sums it up with
this really striking line.
You can call it exploitation,
you can call it freedom.
You'd be right both ways.
Exploitation and freedom at the
same time.
That's yeah, that's messy.
It is messy, no easy labels fit.
So how do people like navigate
this system day-to-day,
especially with policy shifting
crackdowns happening?
Our source mentioned something
about the border itself, right?
This is another kind of twist in
the narrative.
It suggests that for millions,
yeah, the cage is real enough.
The threat of deportation,
detention, it's real, but it's
also described as a revolving
door.
A revolving door?
How does that work?
Well, it's presented as this
kind of open secret,
particularly among the drywall
king types.
They know how to slip out now.
Come back when the winds change.
So wait for a different
administration, different
policies.
Exactly.
When the White House flips, when
the policy, it's soft again.
The analogy used is pretty
vivid.
The bar never really closes, it
just kicks you out to the curb
so you can sneak in through the
kitchen next week.
Huh.
So it suggests a certain
permeability, Yeah, despite the
walls in the rhetoric.
A definite permeability, and
it's framed not as some big
hidden conspiracy, but more like
like a handshake deal that no
one wants to name out loud.
An unspoken understanding.
Precisely which leads to this
idea of the liminal migrant.
Liminal.
Beaten on the threshold, half
in, half out, Living and working
off the books, maybe for years.
Often essential to certain
industries, but without official
status.
Existing in the margins.
And the source offers a theory
about this right about the role
these migrants play.
Yes, and it's quite provocative.
It argues that the modern
liminal migrant is a walking
development grant.
Walking Development grant
explain that.
The idea is they function as a
self extracting loan from
America's shadow labor market.
All that money wired home
billions globally.
It props up the economies of
poorer countries.
So instead of official foreign
aid.
Instead of IMF loans with
strings attached or World Bank
policies dictating terms, you
have this direct flow of cash.
The source calls it usury, but
voluntary.
Usury, but voluntary.
Meaning yeah, takes a huge toll.
Give 10 years of your spine,
your lungs, your liver, it says.
Basically sacrifice your health
and youth.
Send the earnings South.
And come home a king.
It's a stark trade off your body
for capital essentially, but it
bypasses the official aid
systems entirely.
That's a really powerful and
frankly kind of disturbing way
to frame.
It it is, and it gets right at
the uncomfortable economic
realities underpinning a lot of
this.
Which, unsurprisingly, triggers
really strong reactions in
people.
The source talks about a gag
reflex.
Yeah, that collective.
Oh fuck no.
Feeling, as the source puts it,
when things feel like too much.
What triggers it?
What's too much?
According to this analysis, it's
things like hearing too many
languages no one translates,
seeing familiar neighborhoods
change, maybe chain stores turn
to fortresses where the old
neighbors don't belong anymore.
It's that feeling of alienation
in your own space.
A sense of displacement maybe?
Could be, and the source makes
this point about Trump saying
he's the cold sore, not the
cause.
Meaning he didn't create the
underlying issue.
Right.
He didn't invent the infection,
as it's called, but maybe he
just makes you look at it,
forces a confrontation with
feelings that were already
simmering.
And is there historical
precedent for this gag reflex,
this reaction?
Oh, absolutely.
The source points to numerous
examples.
The Chinese Exclusion Act back
in 1882 that was largely driven
by white workers feeling
undercut?
OK.
Or think about the Japanese
internment camps during World
War 2, described here as a panic
reaction, a nation's immune
system flaring up in fear.
So this pattern of backlash, of
fear of the other, it's not new.
Not at all.
It's a recurring theme, and the
source argues that that polite
people, maybe mainstream
society, often struggle with
this.
Oh, so they can't stand to admit
that this is how the monster
really eats?
It's easier to romanticize
immigration or just demonize
specific figures like Trump than
to confront the messy, sometimes
ugly underlying dynamics of
cultural change and economic
anxiety.
They want a simpler story.
Which brings us to these
metaphors the source uses about
soup.
Ah yes, the soup analogies.
They're quite good actually.
There's Mulligan's Stew versus
stone soup.
What's the difference?
OK, so Mulligan's do think Great
Depression hobos.
Everyone throws whatever scraps
they have into a communal pot.
You survive on the mix.
It's about collective survival
with whatever is available.
Got it.
And stone soup.
Stone soup is from that folk
tale, right?
Someone starts with just a stone
and water, but convinces
villagers to each add something.
A carrot and onion, a bone.
It implies everyone contribute
something specific to build the
meal.
So in the American context, the
Stone Soup idea is that
immigrants are expected to
contribute something.
Exactly.
Everyone's supposed to drop
something in the pot.
That's the expectation.
And this connects to the idea of
the good immigrant.
Precisely like the source
mentions the Irish grandmother
who lands with 50 bucks in a tin
trunk and builds a life, or the
Vietnamese family who opened the
faux shop and taught the kids to
call the health inspector Sir.
People who visibly add to the
pot integrate, build something
recognized by the community.
But the source suggests there's
tension here, that not everyone
fits that mold or wants to.
Right, that's where the metaphor
gets tricky.
Not every stone makes the soup
better, it argues.
Meaning Meaning some people
maybe want to sip the broth and
throw the bones back in your
face.
Or they want the cash, not the
flag.
They're not interested in adding
to the communal pot in the
expected way.
They have different goals like
the drywall or sending money
home.
Exactly.
And the source suggests the
system America kind of runs on
both the traditional Stone Soup
immigrants and the hustlers.
But that gag reflex comes
roaring back when the balance
feels off.
When the soup gets too rich with
freeloaders or too poor with
pride, that's a striking phrase.
It is it captures that perceived
tension between contribution,
assimilation and just pure
economic transaction and.
To dig into that more, the
sources layout three different
archetypes of immigrants, though
they stress the lines are really
blurry.
Very blurry.
No neat border between the guest
worker and the invader, it says.
No clear line between the
refugee and the opportunist.
OK, so what's the first
archetype?
1st is the stone soup immigrant.
This is the classic narrative.
They come to marry America.
Maybe they drop some old
culture, but they let the new
broth American culture flavor
them.
Their kids speak English.
Right.
Grandkids might barely remember
the old language.
They buy a house.
Plant roots join the PTA.
They're adding to the soup.
OK, archetype too.
That's the liminal guest worker,
I think the drywall king we
talked about or the Bulgarian
lifeguard example you use.
The ones here for the hustle.
Exactly.
Wants the money, not the flag.
The plan is often to go back
home eventually.
Sometimes they do, sometimes
they don't.
America, the source says, kind
of loves them in the shadows.
Hates them in the spotlight.
Needs the labor, dislikes the
presence.
Something like that.
OK.
And the third one. 3rd is the
opportunist or exported problem.
This is the darker archetype.
How so?
It's the idea that some
countries, smart countries,
might actively empty its prisons
and its sanitariums and put them
on the boat.
Offloading their problems, yeah.
The source sends examples like
Castro during the Mariel
boatlift, maybe Balkan warlords
getting rid of rivals or
oligarchs moving inconvenient
people out of the way.
So people who aren't necessarily
fleeing persecution in the
traditional sense, but are being
pushed out for other reasons,
sometimes nefarious ones.
Exactly now it's crucial.
Here, the source emphasizes that
genuine refugees absolutely
exist and find safety in
America.
Right.
It mentions Vietnam, boat
people, Jewish exiles fleeing
the Nazis, Cubans escaping
Castro, the whole framework of
asylum, the Geneva Convention.
They exist for real reasons.
That humanitarian impulse is
real, but.
There's always a butt in this
analysis, isn't there?
There usually is.
The counterpoint is that for
every real refugee, there's an
opportunist, A remittance
warrior, a Trojan horse of bad
actors that any state would be
foolish to ignore.
So it's naive to think everyone
arriving has the same motives or
background.
According to this view, yes.
It argues that states need to be
pragmatic, even cynical
sometimes, about who's crossing
their borders.
So then there's the risk of
becoming too cynical, right?
Absolutely.
The source poses that critical
question.
If you abandon the moral high
ground entirely, you risk
becoming the monster you fear.
A total no one gets in policy,
it suggests, would corrode
America's own values, its own
soul.
So it's this constant balancing
act, compassion versus perceived
national interest, moral ideals
versus pragmatic security.
A very difficult tightrope to
walk.
No easy answers.
Let's shift slightly and talk
about the money again.
Remittances, that secret river
of cash flowing back home.
Yeah, the scale is just immense.
We're talking billions upon
billions globally.
And the stats you mentioned
earlier, remittances surpassing
foreign direct investment in
many countries like Mexico
getting nearly $60 billion in
2023.
Right.
Or making up over 20% of GDP in
places like El Salvador and
Honduras.
It's a huge economic force.
And the argument is that this
money often does more good on
the ground than official aid.
That's a key point in the source
material because it goes
directly to families, It
bypasses government corruption,
bureaucratic bloat.
It's used for immediate needs,
food, housing, maybe starting a
small Business, School fees.
Direct impact.
Very direct, far more targeted
you could argue, than large
scale development project that
might not benefit ordinary
people.
OK, but there has to be a
downside.
What's the counter argument
presented?
The counter is significant.
The source calls it a bullshit
check.
These remittance economies,
while providing A lifeline, can
also breed dependency.
How so?
Well, they can drain the home
country of its most ambitious,
hard working people, the very
ones needed for local
development.
And they can reduce pressure for
real political and economic
reform back home.
Like why demand better
governance if your uncle in
Virginia is sending cash every
month?
Exactly.
It can create a sort of
complacency, potentially
stalling deeper change.
And then there's the question of
romanticizing the struggle.
What do you mean?
Are we just celebrating the
drywaller's hustle without
acknowledging how brutal and
exploitative that work often is?
Are we letting the system off
the hook?
The system that relies on that
cheap labor?
Relies on cheap fruit, cheap
construction, clean lawns, often
with no questions asked.
That's the uncomfortable truth,
the source pushes.
And this leads to the charge of
hypocrisy, particularly aimed at
polite people.
Yes, the source is quite pointed
here, talking about those who
lecture about compassion but
might simultaneously benefit
indirectly from this shadow
economy.
People who might cross the
street before they push through
the Poo Poosa Bar door at
midnight.
Right.
Enjoying the benefits of cheap
labor while maintaining a kind
of deliberate distance or
ignorance about the human cost.
The source is blunt.
They think no one notices.
Everyone notices.
That lands hard.
It's meant to.
It suggests this disconnect,
this perceived hypocrisy, is
itself a major source of
resentment and contributes to
that gag reflex.
One thing that really comes
through is that none of this is
actually new.
These cycles, these tensions,
they happened before in American
history.
Repeatedly, the source is
adamant about this.
It's not trying to be anti
immigrant, it's trying to be
anti bullshit as it says pro
honesty about these recurring
patterns.
Can you give some examples it
uses?
Sure.
Think way back to the 1700s.
The indentured Irish.
Were there refugees, economic
migrants, Exploited labor?
Kind of all three, right?
Half refugee, half economic
slave.
OK, what else?
The Chinese railroad workers in
the 19th century recruited,
welcomed for their labor, then
intensely disliked,
discriminated against,
eventually excluded when the
work was done or the economy
shifted.
Invited, then hated.
A classic pattern.
Then there was Operation Wetback
in 1954, mass deportations of
Mexican workers.
But predictably, the demand for
labor returned and the doors
implicitly opened again.
Back and forth.
Always back and forth even after
World War 2 welcoming displaced
persons but with strict vetting
and screening.
Or the Mariel boatlift in 1980
you mentioned.
Where Castro sent prisoners and
others.
Right, A huge influx causing
major social challenges in
places like Miami.
Many of those arrivals
eventually built lives and
communities despite the
difficult circumstances and the
initial exported problem aspect.
So the point is.
These debates, these anxieties,
the mix of people arriving for
different reasons, it's baked
into the American experience,
deeply baked.
In the source suggests the gag
reflex kicks in when it feels
like the deal changed, or maybe
the lie got too obvious, the lie
being the.
Kayfabe, the gap between the
official story and the ground
reality could be.
Or maybe it's just hitting a
perceived limit, a feeling that
there's a limit to how many
separate kingdoms can exist
inside a single town.
It's about social cohesion,
feeling strained.
So where?
Does this leave us if this big
beautiful bill isn't the answer?
If these patterns just repeat,
what's the take away?
Well, the source is pretty.
Clear The bill itself won't
fundamentally fix anything.
It won't change the drywaller's
motivation.
It won't suddenly make someone
choose the flag over sending
money home.
It won't make.
Polite white kids tell the truth
about who keeps their salads
crisp and their lawns cut
exactly that line.
Cuts deep.
The argument is that the bill,
like many before it, probably
just feeds the monster the same
calories it's always craved.
Cheap labor, cheap fear, cheap
moral cover.
So no Easy.
Solutions offered here?
Nope, the source.
Explicitly says no fix, no
moral.
It's just laying out the messy,
contradictory reality as it sees
it.
Just the truth.
Or truth.
At least a raw truth.
And the final thought it leaves
you with is pretty potent.
It insists the soup never stops.
The monster never starves.
This whole process, this
dynamic, it just keeps going.
So what does American.
Independence even taste like
then in this view, maybe the.
Source suggests it tastes like a
soup full of bones.
A gag you can't quite swallow.
A fireworks show over an
unfinished wall.
Wow.
It's quite an image, a gag.
You can't quite swallow it is it
leaves you.
Chewing on this idea, and maybe
the only real choice is whether
you gag on your own illusions or
swallow the monster hole.
Acknowledge the whole difficult,
messy reality.
No easy answers.
Today, then, just a lot to think
about.
Definitely not.
A comforting picture perhaps,
but maybe a more honest 1A
braver way to look at it all.